hello
hi hello what's up
welcome to simulation
you for having me so pumped
me too me too
no idea what's gonna happen but we'll
see
accept yourself it's gonna happen
the sharing of what is a critical
component for becoming the creator
for god realization yes
yeah often overstepped often overseen
often overlooked at and and
yeah good luck becoming the creator from
resistance
yeah and
yeah typically seen as these
flare-ups of
conditioning so anger or resentment or
fear or anxiety or unworthiness or
un unlovability and
that
by shining the light of awareness on
these sub subconscious fortifications
they lovingly dissolve and
are integrated healed
and then we can more cohesively
harmonically vibrate as
that very infinitude and
intelligence yeah
nice well said you pay attention
i need attention in mark's accept
yourself
two program and
accept yourself three is coming up
and that is july 7th
august 8th yep yep
and so it's easy to remember seven seven
to eight eight
and and so
mark's taken
is it 50 people right yeah
approximately yeah since february
since february 50 people have won on the
accept yourself
program with mark and
i'm excited to talk about that on the
show and help it
share with more of our
audience and more
land in the hearts of
you all because it's such a critical
component
in the process and i'm excited for mark
to be able to share it and we also have
some
um nice visualizations to help
along the way let's play for a bit with
mark's
um trajectory and how he yeah
how he got to where he's at cool
long story short but
uh it is a long story and i might write
a book at some point
because it's so multifaceted and
cool so and
when i share my story whoever's
listening
like see if you can relate to this to
your own story as you're listening
um so
i was born
i wasn't but i was um
in the first few years of my life i was
like connected
to source to energies i could see like
orbs flying around and like i could just
feel
the oneness with everything
i remember this first thought i had i
was like two years old
laying in my bed in my childhood house
where i grew up and
looking at the ceiling and
i had these moments in those first
few years where something would come
over me and i would feel
as if i was an alien like as if this
wasn't my planet
i was like what what the hell it wasn't
my body even
sounds were like were just alien
like and so it wasn't this state and i
remember
thinking like of course these were
abstract concepts
back then but looking back from
from now it's like it was like what is
this
what am i doing here like really like
contemplative right at two years old i
was like what the [ __ ]
and so i was pretty happy
the first few years and then i went to
elementary school
that's where it all went down the drain
and because i had growth problems i
my body was smaller than average and i
had glasses
so immediately coming into elementary
school especially
like after a few years two or three
years
i started getting bullied and
i was a catholic school so i was i was
like
not really brought abstractly catholic
at home but we
we were put in a catholic school and we
did celebrate easter and like
uh christmas and we went to church and
stuff like that
and i got this children's bible
and as it was rea i read this every
every night before going to sleep and i
connected really with the essence
of christ so not
the person but actually the energy and i
felt like wow like
this is my only friend like i can trust
this guy
i didn't trust anybody in school and
like
so i'm like i can trust this guy and
i i really believe that in in that
and um
then the last few years of of uh
of elementary school which you would
call like before high school
just before high school
i started getting aggravate like is it
aggravated when somebody attacks you
yeah like so i used to walk home from
school
and just randomly these kids would
assault me and i was like what the [ __ ]
why is this happening to me right so
that's
we're gonna come back to this uh
perspective that i had like
why is this happening to me like
if god is real like why would this
happen to me
right so i started losing my faith i
started losing that and
especially when i went to high school i
was this angry atheist
i was like god doesn't exist only
science exists
uh only evolution exists i always
believed in aliens
but and ancient civilizations and stuff
like that but god i was like
okay they fooled me like they fooled me
with easter bunny and like with santa
claus
jesus didn't exist it was just a fairy
tale
so i felt betrayed i felt like angry
so for most of my teen and that doesn't
mean that i didn't have fun
i had fun but still the fun was there
was always a shadow
behind that
and
let me see
see if i can tell the story without
angering my mom
i can tell you this i i took it i made
it made a few decisions
which led me into prison
and those decisions were
so because i would lost my faith and i
was a smaller than average boy
most of my life i was trying to prove my
worth
outside of myself right i was trying to
be good i was trying to
i was debating with other people just to
be right just to feel good about myself
yeah i'm right i feel good about myself
i feel strong i feel empowered
right and so i came out of my first
long relationship she lived in another
city and i went back to my hometown and
some friends of mine were doing
mischievous stuff and i felt like i had
to prove myself so
we started doing this mischievous stuff
and i was good at it
so like we're going to come back to that
as well
achieving so i was good at something for
the first time in my life
why would i stop it was also making me
money so didn't that makes
of course i got busted and went to
prison and that's where
i think was the start of the shift
came out got new friends for the first
time in my life i felt like
i had friends that had my back that i
could trust not that
not that the friends that i had before
weren't trusted but i just didn't trust
myself and i didn't trust them so
after i came out of prison i got new
friends
and i felt like they were reflections of
where i was at
then growing more into self-love
i started doing ecstasy and like all
that kind of stuff
drugs and party scenes and festivals and
after parties and like cocktails of
eight different substances and like
looking
like finding the edge of consciousness
and having these trippy experiences and
of course that wasn't sustainable either
so after like
one and a half years of every few months
sometimes a few times per month
uh partying all the dopamine
and serotonin and all the good stuff
and my brain was depleted and so i was
laying on the floor thinking like how
can i live with myself
like i can't go on like this because i'm
one
i'm numb two only when i party i feel
good
three when i don't party the friends
that i party with
i need them to validate my worth
and so i was like depleted because i was
constantly seeking outside of myself
for uh worthiness
empowerment feeling good about myself
all of that stuff and so i was like okay
something needs to change
and one of my other good friends an
amazing artist
um he was like 10 years or 12 years
older than me so a little wiser he
quit drinking alcohol or using any
substances
30 years before and he started he was
meditating already for a few decades so
he told me about meditation and
at first before that breakdown moment i
was like meditation i'm not a
woo boo like hippie you know totally
judging it
and he taught me this meditation so i
went to him and i asked him
dude like i need help or i'm
or i don't know what to do right
and he said try this practice it's a
combination of two practices
one before you go to sleep because i
told him
the worst moments were before falling
asleep because i was worrying about
everything
and like worrying about people leaving
me and then that meant that i wasn't
worth yet like all of that stuff right
so i went to bed worrying
every single night for most of my life
actually
since my childhood and so he told me
okay do this before you go to sleep lay
down take a few deep breaths
deep into your into your abdomen
and feel the energy in your separate
body part so start with your right foot
then start
and feel your calf and feel your thigh
bone then feel your
hips and so on and so on
then as you start to feel calm as your
nervous system comes down
try to observe your thoughts as if
you're laying in the grass field on a
sunny day and there are
the clouds are passing by and the clouds
are
thoughts so i was like cool i can do
that and i did
and it was easy and sometimes when it
was less easy when it was about a
certain family member or whatever
labeling the thought
labeling the cloud oh family oh work it
helped with
letting it pass by so i was doing this
practice for like
three weeks and
three weeks into the practice i'm laying
in bed and this automatic meditative
state
so it was already having its effect it
was already part
of my conditioning already the
meditation
practice
reconditioning not unconscious
conditioning
of course um
so i'm laying in bed in this state and
all of a sudden these
images pass by but they were
non-personal they were about humanity
as all like as a whole so i see this
ancient civilizations like atlantis and
egypt and
sumeria and jerusalem i just see it pass
by
as vivilly as i'm seeing you right now
in my mind's eye and the moment the
images shift to the present
they fast forward i don't know how far
into the future
and what i felt in that moment was
something that that this big of a shift
i haven't felt actually since that
moment
where i felt this love that
was i felt this love
with doing ecstasy with my friends but
this
it was like the the party love that i
felt and this love was
the party love was a fragment of what i
was feeling
it was this immense love which was
everywhere but i was that
yeah yeah and there was no separation
between me and that love and that look
it felt a little feminine felt like it
was holding me
and it has always been holding me even
when i was an angry atheist
it was still hauling me and i was one
with that
and it was one with everything and i
knew and i felt and i experienced in
that moment that
there's no separation everything is me
not me mark but me that is
beyond as you know and
this is a this is a little flak apple
you would say that that's where
uh from that moment forward everything
was peaceful right now
that's where it started that's where it
started my friend
that's where the unconditioning started
right so i had this gl
this awakening this glimpse this which
even in the hard times i could go back
to that so
it did make everything easy and this was
like 11 years ago
and it's been 11 years of
finding what that was and trying
different practices and finding
different teachers like muji and akatoli
i've done
so much great work with akathali's books
like without actually i would wouldn't
be here
uh definitely so much impact it's had
um the team was sorrow of course
big impact and a lot of the practices
that
i'm doing in the program
i've learned from him and i've applied
that and the admitting defeat which
we'll be going into
is one of the biggest things that have
made the biggest impact because
so 11 years ago i was 26
i had this awakening moment but it was
26
of 26 years of any anytime
something didn't go my way
this core assumption of there's
something wrong with me came up right
and i believed in it for 26 years
so over the course of the last 11 years
up until like two and a half years ago
it was still coming up and i was still
operating from that
when it came up i was still believing in
it
and that's where you accept yourself
comes in right
so until i got a reflection
from my dear friend bentino he said
you've done so much work i'm
paraphrasing this is not
literal but you've done so much work
but your shadow is still operating the
show
to some extent and this is my invitation
to you do you wish to eliminate your
shadow once and for all
and my my answer was yes and and it was
uncomfortable because i was seeing
how much in my spiritual practice
i was still trying to disprove yeah
there's something wrong with me i was
still trying to prove that there's
nothing wrong with me
in my outward actions not all the time
but even in the 80 80 70 60
of the time i wasn't doing that the
shadow off there could be something
wrong with me was still
somewhere in the background lingering
so know yourself that
and and those i've had many of those of
different moments in the last 11 years
where know myself those awakening
moments happened
uh it's crazy moments where you're like
oh [ __ ] were you actually standing still
and
practicing act ecotoli's power of no
like
oh [ __ ] i believe that there is time but
actually
when i stopped there is no
i i can only find now the rest is in my
mind
tomorrow is in my mind yesterday's in my
mind four weeks ago is in my mind
so let's know yourself right and that's
great
it's great to practice
but know yourself also has to do with
knowing what you're not
and that is where accept acceptance
comes in like
oh i picked up this belief there's
something wrong with me
and i'm accepting that i did otherwise
i'm gonna
chase my until trying to disprove this
assumption
in my spiritual practice also
and then my outward actions with helping
others and like
all of that
so yeah this is a nutshell yeah
my life of course the last 11 years like
there's a whole
spectrum of experiences i've had and
challenges i've
i've been through and for sure
but in a nutshell that's where this is
like the
the how it cracks of it i think yeah
yeah yeah
i love how you mentioned this
at such a young age for yourself where
you delivered this question
of who am i what am i doing here
and usually this is a question that
comes up only in the teens or even in
the 20s or sometimes in the 30s as these
like midlife
crises
and then
that in a sense ends up becoming one of
if if we truly increase our desire
to 11 and we just
fan the flame of of desire of that
question we can through a process of
deduction um using the intellect
as siddhar mishwar maharaja
guru says that we can take this bird's
way
to the nature of reality and so yes
and so that biggest
question is such a huge
if we turn the knob of desire up
and fan the flame can take us uh
through the know yourself accept
yourself become the creator foo
rocket ship yeah yeah and so
i i also really love how um you had this
process of the low of the roller coaster
and i feel so many similar vibes as
you were sharing where
you know being um being sh
being shorter and being um you said
glasses
and having this um
for me it was being called jelly belly
because i was
fatter than the other kids and and that
there's all of this i love how you view
it as that there's all of the
subconscious conditioning that the
individuated mind body spirit complex
picks up
that we don't we don't
clearly know ourselves
at those deepest layers of the
subconscious which is also
what buddha taught in the process of
stilling yourself
using the breath to the point of which
you can get to these deepest roots
of suffering and
i love that practice that was also
shared
by your friend and it was after prison
as well so i also went to
jail for four months for mischievous
stuff
and that's these lowest lows that are so
transformative and we when we look back
we can really be like blessed by
those experiences that then
rocket shipped us upward
on the roller coaster yep
and your your friend's recommendation
was really
efficient because yeah it's such a
simple
one is to leverage the breath
and then to leverage all these different
releasings of tension
across the body just feeling into that
calf
and the quad and the torso
and the neck and the shoulder it's
such a useful practice and then further
and then further more the very classic
one that's been used across these mystic
traditions of
juxtaposing the the clouds
that appear and disappear with the sky
that is the background the the awareness
the beingness the i am-ness and
then going through a process of
having the nature more and more revealed
to you
via direct experience by this turn
inward at that level of subtlety
yeah and then yeah 100 and and then
what happened was i started to attract
people that match that
growth and that inner and then the
the paradox for me was i'm i'm
attracting
attracting these reflections that are
reflecting my
expansion and my expanding in self-love
and then the
slow down is to not make it about those
other reflections
to not try to seek validation from those
outside reflections and
so that was a big big journey for me
to actually see that where i was still
in my spiritual growth still operating
from
there's something wrong with me i need
somebody to
tell me that there's nothing wrong with
me
it was wow it was painful
like to see that to actually see that to
actually see
oh [ __ ] i'm operating from this yes
but it's fine it's fine to see that
yep the the activity of
watching the the clouds is
like the first pillar know yourself
because you're watching the frames of
your life
more vigilantly and so you're
getting to know yourself at a more
intimate level where
you don't just jump between thought
clouds
without any idea of vigilance of
watching yourself but instead now you
become
way more hyper conscious and vigilant
of the thought clouds the emotions the
beliefs all these things appearing and
disappearing
and then the space opens up more and
more as you do this investigative
process
of that that sky-like awareness
beingness i am-ness and like you said
when you had this
the this feeling of the
god's love that transcends
everything that is possible in
uh any entheogenic experience
um even giving birth to a child in
in in a nuclear family um
because you you recognize that the
every subatomic particle is
made of love but and and then
um and then then then the process i like
how you describe it that that
even from that point it's still a
beginning of this new chapter
because then there's the process of
creating a
in this accept yourself part and
becoming the creator part
there's a juxtaposition that's still
created
between where i'm coming from
that's the seems to be the easiest way
to describe it is
am i coming from the place where every
subatomic particle
is god's love or am i coming from
the place of i still need to be seen
or validated as worthy by my family and
by my friends
by my peers and the last uh i would
the last how can you call it
is it this state of consciousness or is
it the state of being
like that coming from needing to be
validated
that is the state of most of humanity i
would say
at this point
that is why the rat race is there
that's why it exists because because
you're validated by your actions right
in the in the conventional world
and
[Music]
when i'm coming from
as i as i said as in
in the calling work words like being
touched by god's love
people being touched by god's love then
if i'm coming from that when i'm coming
from that
i don't need to be validated by anything
outside of myself because
i like what the [ __ ] like god's love
what else do you need
then it's not any more about gaining
something
from something it is radiating
out that
yes exactly paradoxically so you'll get
like you get everything you need but
that's
it's not about that this is a probably a
good time to bring up the
admitting defeat visualization of the
core curriculum cool yeah
okay all right so
one of the core curriculas of the
accept yourself program and also passed
along by bentino
um is this admitting defeat to your core
lack belief or weakness
um which we were just explaining in this
visualization
you can see the mouse cursor here that
within this manifestation chessboard
is where you're you're seeking the
validation
worthiness fame money because you're
playing in this lower frequency
of i will be seen and i will be worthy
yeah and
and it really requires to see that
you're coming from like we were saying
the place of
having a lack i lack therefore i need
yeah i like love so i need a partner
for example yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're um and then what's
so beautiful about this is when you sort
of
are able to visualize it and recognize
that when you sort of
surrender when you get to this higher
frequency zone of i surrender and i
admit defeat to this
to this chess game of of fighting for
validation worthiness
money fame love um you tip over the king
it enables the shift from this person
to this godson state
of i am already always worthy my cup is
already always 100 full
yeah or to quote bentino again
but i think more people have said this
the mere fact that you
are you are
you exist let's prove enough that's
enough proof that you are worthy because
you are
you exist what else do you need right
but to get to that place i get it
because if you believe that you're not
worthy
you believe that you need to achieve
something that you've believed in that
for most of your life that you need to
achieve something to feel
good about yourself you need that money
you need that job you need that
partner you need a family you need
whatever you want whatever you project
outside of yourself as a desire and then
when i have that
then then i'm worthy and if i can't have
it
then it perpetuates itself this belief
i'm unworthy i'm a worthy i'm
worthy of my words even if you attract a
partner
it will blow up in your face at some
point
so the practice here is
to really slow down
and actually see without judgment
where you've been coming from for most
of your life
what is that that's been operating on
the background
and you you of course you need the light
of awareness for that
to shine the light on that and then with
me it was
one of the biggest triggers for me was
failure
and what failure triggered was this
belief that there's something wrong with
me
so before i was aware of this
my action looked like trying to prove
myself right
i was a master debater for most of my
life
i felt so good by myself if i was right
but i felt so shitty if i was right and
people were not validating that
or if we played a terrible soccer game
and the plane was put on me
i felt [ __ ] for like five days because i
felt actually i believe that that meant
that there was something wrong with me
right so to actually slow
down and see that what wow
i do believe there's something wrong
with me
i do believe i'm not good enough okay
[ __ ] it i'm not trying to fight it
anymore i'm not trying to prove it wrong
see how paradoxically paradoxical that
was like i tried to
i'm trying to prove wrong the belief
that there's something wrong with me
it's like double wrong
like
so
slowing down and and seeing that and
then being
okay like one of the things that we said
in the program was
something wrong with me so what
actually being curious what happens
when we do that that counter-intuitive
response because the the
normal response is trying to fight it
right
especially as we become more aware
spiritually and more aware of
awareness and consciousness oh
i believe there's something wrong with
me that can't be right because i know
i'm worthy
uh so let me try like that it's it's
like the same game as being played
even when you're becoming more aware
but you there's no need to prove it
wrong
just accept it
accept that part of your consciousness
has believed in that
and the analogy i use oftentimes
is
there is a child aspect of you that
actually believes
and that right what was your core
assumption
atlas oh
i will never be seen yeah that i
and that i need to attain these
metaphysical credits to be seen
by my family and by my friends by my
peers
yep yeah so that's the outward
expression and
the assumption is i will not i will
never be seen some
i will never be seen something along
those lines
with me there's some there's something
wrong with me
and so
there's a child aspect of yourself
that where it was picked up somewhere
like somewhere in my life
something happened i did something when
i was in my child like happy state
i did something and there was something
said mark you did something wrong like
that's where it starts probably mom
father
like most mostly that's where it starts
and then everything that happened after
that is like proof that
it amplifies that core assumption um
like the being bullied was amplifying
the core assumption but i believe it it
was picked up even before i went to
school
like whatever i did in my house like
i accidentally hit my brother or
whatever whatever happened
but so there is a child aspect that
actually believes
in that moment it's almost as if it's
frozen in time
there's something wrong with me and it
feels bad
because it's it's not true right but but
there it's believed in
and so whenever something happens in
your life
that in your adult life it triggers that
core assumption
so it triggers that child that is frozen
in time so to speak
yeah and what you've been doing so far
i'm i'm making a generalization
i'm not it doesn't mean that you're it
discounts for everybody who's listening
but
what you've been doing so far is
you're wrong you're wrong
i'm gonna try to prove you wrong so i'm
gonna try to outwardly prove you wrong
so invalidating the child basically yep
yep what happens then is that the child
takes over and it wants to validate it
so
blah blah but what we're doing in this
practice is being like
you win you're right
what do you need there's something wrong
there's something wrong with you
so what what does it actually mean i'm
here for you
you stop the fight
and then what happens is it
it seems truthable it sees through
an accuracy of the statement but not by
anything but acceptance yes
it dissolves but not by fighting it it
dissolves by letting it win
yeah getting giving the child what it
needs
and then the more you do this practice
the more
it becomes natural the
response it's like you're in
conventional
terms it's like you're creating new
neural pathways in your brain
i was i was about to play with that
analogy
so as though there is this
this portion of the neural architecture
from the youth that is conditioned
with the this subconscious
belief of i lack or i am unworthy
or i am unloved
and then
because it's subconscious we then
through our
teens and 20s and 30s onward
that we go through a process of
subconsciously aiming to
through everything that we do in life
to get
the validation of what was
seeking validation in this portion of
neural architecture
or getting worthiness if in the neural
architecture was
unworthiness or unlovability so we're
trying to get love
and so um it's really cool that
when we take this light of awareness and
we
and we you know it's so so common that
the
that it's focused outward and when we
turn it
inward and we put the light of awareness
on the areas of neural architecture that
we were just talking about
these areas of subconscious conditioning
where i look at in
in my life that i had
this
armenian immigrant family that was
adamant about finishing
college and becoming a very
uh successful immigrant family
and that
then there was this process also
upon leaving college to
seek more entrepreneurial success and
more
truth in silicon valley
there was this process of constantly
seeing that
in this packet of neural architecture
that and i didn't notice this but that
until
just very recently that there was
constantly this process of
looking at my mom and at my uncle and
that my peers that were watching me at
the community i was watching
me and wondering when am i going to
attain
enough money or fame or worthiness or
validation
enough metaphysical credits that this
this kid
went out and he found something that was
so valuable and he started sharing it
with the world that now
i can feel valid i can feel worthy i can
that type of process and by turning the
light of awareness on that package
of neural architecture subconscious
beliefs
slowly over time they became loved
and accepted radically as they are
and then it sort of enabled the the
shift in frequency
from the the chess game to
um the godson state where i'm always
already 100 worthy and free and my cup
is always 100
full and then the attention shifted from
um how can how can i
um like post something onto
uh let's say instagram that then
makes it so that although it's like a
mixed bag where
a one percentage of it is about
being seen but another percentage of it
is about
saying something that serves other
people and then that shifts from
being a mixed bag to how can i
only come from making a post that
is focused only exclusively on how
other people will use this post for
their own process of knowing themselves
accepting themselves and becoming the
creator
and yeah so that was this big shift that
happens is
not coming from the place of being seen
but coming from the place of only
focusing
on serving other people nice
yeah yeah because if you want to be seen
then you're not seeing yourself
so when you see yourself completely
then there's no need to be seen in a
certain way
and then it's about what you said like
how can i bring
what i've learned to others
how can i condense in my case 11 years
of learning
into a 30-day package well just do it
yeah and it's been great like this
program has been great
it's been so awesome to do this
in a sense every single one of these 50
people
and that like you indicated there's so
many
billions of people around the planet
that in in essence have
as we talked about this portion of
subconscious neural architecture
[Music]
and that they're playing this game
but that they don't know that they're
playing this game because there's
there's never been a map or
somebody like you with the program to
help them
understand that they're playing this
game and
and that by highlighting that they're
playing this game and by
seeing the portion of their neural
architecture that has a subconscious
lack belief um
that then that enables them to see that
these higher frequencies even exist
and that all that they have to do is
surrender it and defeat
to this lack belief and weakness
um and then that area of neural
architecture
becomes um healed by this i am
already always worthy god's son essence
yes you are because you
are i am that i am
or just you are just because you
are is auto worthiness
auto worthiness full 100 cut full
is just because you are just imagine
what kind of planet we would have if
everybody would just believe that they
are
already worthy
ah you're so cute yeah
yeah yeah she joined the previous
program and she's gonna join the next
one as well
and i feel really great about her
journey
thank you so much
so loving
i love that visual you were just taking
us on a planet
where the corlac beliefs
have been healed and that we feel
100 worthy and full
one step at a time yep yep
yeah so then there's another really good
um visual that we can pull up that is
helpful
which is this one so
throughout the program mark
goes through a process of tailoring
these reflections to each individual
that is going through the program and so
for me
the the tailored reflection was when
recognizing when i'm coming from needing
to be seen
as the lightbringer and so this is a
shirt
yeah exactly
and
and then each one of these reflections
is
tailored to each
individual going through the program to
exactly where they're at
with their process that then helps them
accept themselves and go to this
higher frequency higher state of of
being
yeah exactly and
in the first session i asked people what
their intention is
how they see themselves in their already
radically accepting
version and i'm asking them what is
holding them back from that
and and that is this but and then in the
second session we actually
define what is that core assumption
and then this happens and and i have an
amazing team that
also helps with documenting those things
so i actually have these things on paper
so i can
go back to this and hold people
accountable
as i've done with you and yeah that was
great
like like just
that thing where you said
you want to get credits or something
yeah metaphysical credit
and whenever i felt that come up in the
program i was like hey atlas
are you seeing this because you want to
get credits
yes yes exactly just perfect
so good so so you if we if we broke this
down it would be that
there's a um
within the accept yourself program
there's a portion of it at the early
part
where there's the um what would it look
like
if you did erratically fully
um accept yourself and then
and then that would be like um
that um i will maybe always come from a
place of being whole
already um and then
in this kind of like second portion like
it's like what is maybe holding you
back from that yep
and then in my case it was needing to be
seen
as the lightbringer like wanting to be
seen
as that in this and in an analogy of
that little
area of neural architecture
subconsciously um
uh yeah wanting to be seen by family
peers
validated as worthy and then when you
put it into like a visualization like
this
what you get is you get like a little um
it's like a little like block chained
uh part of your uh know yourself accept
yourself become the creator
mind body spirit complex process is this
little blockchain
graphic reflection of you know mark
reflecting what can be done for this
individuated mind body spirit complex to
no longer come from a place of lack or
unworthiness
but instead to come from a place of
god's son wholeness
perpetually and then now you get this
visualization this reflection graphic
and it's a blockchain for yourself to
look at and be like
i'm done with this i've admitted defeat
i've surrendered
the game where i'm trying to be seen
um and so now i'm coming from a place
of god son where i'm always 100
worthy um and that i will never
be seen because i already am 100
worthy and these these visualizations
are so good these like individuated
tailored reflection visualizations
because it makes it so that the
individuated mind body spirit complex
it
undergoes a process of
radically admitting that they're
getting beyond this and then
another segment i would say is
connecting you to your essence
and connecting you to your soul
connecting you
to that which was already whole
before the conditioning started
connecting you to your true self
as a soul and from that
higher self type of
state of being yeah going and this is
gonna be an element that i'm gonna
implement more and accept yourself three
and going to
your childhood and changing the script
changing the story yeah which
helps with healing that core assumption
like i went back to my childhood
memories and changed the story from
i was being bullied to i was in uh
martial arts
that was all martial arts training yeah
exactly
like that's my story now like and i
actually believe that perfect everything
that's led up to this point was training
and so i wasn't victory to anything
perfect
even when i was physically uh attacked
like it was all training it was training
baby they're all senseis thank you
exactly like what like just like
circumstances
when circumst when there are different
circumstances
the story changes right so of course i
was being attacked i was being
physically like uh attacked but
if i were to be in kung fu school
or
ninjutsu or something if i if i don't
perform then my sense is going to hit me
with a stick on my back right well how
is that different
it's just the perspective the story that
i tell myself that's different but
actually it's not that different
yeah it's not that different from the
little
shaolin monks that go to the monastery
at eight years old and
get not beat into submission but beat
into their best self so that's why i
look at my
life oh my gosh
that's so good yeah that's so good when
when you can go to that package of
subconscious neural architecture and
rather than be a victim
to the narratives that we've been
perpetuating for years
instead to look at that area and to say
that that was my training ground
that was my senseis those were that was
my
martial arts style training that then
enabled me today
to be able to properly be a shepherd or
to be a steward to be in pure service to
others
because of that subconscious
conditioning
it's beautiful rewrite the script
rewrite just rewrite the story yeah yeah
and you can also yeah and and and that's
also because there is no time you can
also do it in future so the moment in
the first session actually
when i ask people to describe what it
would feel like after
what would the version feel like that
already is an erratic
radical acceptance of themselves
they don't notice but they're already
doing the work because
they're writing the script of the future
yeah
it's perfect exactly yup
yup wow that's great
i feel like
we did a pretty good job at covering um
a lot of
what the accept yourself vibe is about
and also
the even metaphysically speaking what
the nature of reality in so many ways is
about
is picking up that contracted separation
energy of the unworthiness energy and
then to
on that turn inward um uh
knowing yourself accepting yourself
becoming the creator the whole game of
metaphysical game that we play
um and how accept yourself is that
core curricula in the process
you can't get around it guys you have to
undergo this process
and it's better to do it earlier you get
that compound interest if you do it in
your
um teens and uh and even earlier than if
you
uh wait until your 20s 30s 40s to give
this a go
i love the comments mk ultra you're
mixing metaphysics with some
simulation science please stop i'm just
sharing from my own experience
and if you want us to stop why are you
here you can just
you can stop watching so namaste
um somebody else is asking but isn't
changing the story
just a rearrangement like the ego like
rearranging the textures
on the titanic
it's working with the ego in my
experience
yeah do you have anything to say on that
yeah imagine that little area of neural
architecture that's been promulgating
this perpetual story
of i lack or i'm unworthy
and then what you're doing is when you
shine the light of awareness
on it you're instead of i was a victim
to this
you say i was the creator of it i it was
my martial arts
belts training process and so that whole
it's it's becoming the creator rather
than being the victim to that
zone it's it's a very important um
process because
the whole game
um metaphysically is about identity as i
said in the law of one the entire game
is about identity are you identified
as uh a victim to that neural
architecture
um to that subconscious conditioning or
are you identified as the very creator
of
your own escape room to break free from
yep we're constantly
telling stories right
[Music]
it's all a story in the end so
nothing wrong with changing the story to
a story that feels absolutely good
it's great um
yeah yeah yeah
so so the
the um accept yourself three
program um the link is in the bio below
to
mark's instagram um and he has a lot of
great content on there to check out
and the also the link to mark's
calendar um for the accept yourself
program the third one
that's coming up july 7th through august
8th
and so there will be probably about 30
people going on that journey again
with mark and there's
two weekly
calls yeah on wednesdays and sundays
on wednesday and sunday at noon pacific
yeah still to be determined but uh
probably two sessions are gonna be a
little earlier because
uh i have an event that i'm going to
myself
um and then we have two guest speakers
amazing friends of mine um
and one other friend of mine she's
leading a coco ceremony at the end
on august 8th so awesome we're excited
about it and also
one session with me one 15 minutes
and you've experienced how effective
they are so effective
yeah that's the personalization and the
tailoring at a
yeah at a deep level so each one of
these sessions
also has a or many of them
have a component where mark walks you
through a
radical self-love and self-acceptance
meditation
and those are really profound and he's
posted
um several of those on his instagram
oh thanks jp that's cute
yeah i think mk ultra wants to be on
your show by the way
[Laughter]
and then there's also
um after the um
the version three there's also
marks in a process of um exploring how
to
piece together a lot of what he's
already done in the first three sessions
into something that people can do
on the um math scales with accepting
themselves
and that's also really exciting to see
how that
unfolds yeah yeah
super excited about taking that offline
and for people that
want to do this on their own pace and
don't have the
bandwidth to commit to such an intensive
container
which it is um to have an online
program format that can be gone through
in their own timing uh with like
homework assignments and stuff like that
so i'm excited about distilling
the best content from the first three
programs and
actually writing out a
program that people can do themselves so
i'm excited about that
yes and then
and then for those that
also would like to
take it up another notch as well you can
check out the link
in the bio as well to the no limit
society
and so um in the no limit society were
really this know yourself accept
yourself becoming the creator
and um being uh guided by bentino um
just stewarding and shepherding this
collective of 120 plus people now
um and um
that there that the vibe there around
the container for
this purification and actualization
is um is
so potent yep yeah for sure
i really enjoy it yes yeah
yeah it's cool yeah and what we'll do
is i think we'll um we'll have these
um these visualizations also
um more available
um around um
um helping um
with uh with maps for um people to
recognize sort of what's going on in
their lives and how to
um radically admit defeat and admit
surrender to these core lacklies
weaknesses and to
um and and also to sort of see these
like individuated style reflections
as we purify ourselves away from the
subconscious conditioning and towards
that godson
um always already whole and worthy so
we'll
will aim to popularize these maps and um
visualizations
for people to more uh frictionlessly
be able to nice yeah
yeah actualize realize so
cool i think that's uh yeah that's a
wrap
yeah that was beautiful yeah thank you
yeah that was really solid and i i it
was just perfect timing
um having gone through the program and
having um been able to
create and collaborate with you for a
period of a couple months
has made me able to be more empty of
that
conditioning and um and more coming from
a place of wholeness
and purity and service and so that's why
the interview felt like it was just way
more divine
um timing yeah yeah perfect
perfect and then for everyone thank you
for tuning in
we love you so much we're super grateful
yeah see you in the program
see you in the program and uh like the
video for brought you value helps
algorithm subscribe to the channel if
you haven't yet let us know your
thoughts in the comments below on what
mark was teaching us around accepting
yourself where you're at in the process
and uh mark can join and uh comment and
chime in
um yeah and share the video with other
people that you feel like would
love to hear about the process of
accepting yourself
and that's all
we love you very much thanks for tuning
in see you in the program
follow mark on instagram too and uh much
love thanks everyone
peace cool i'm gonna end the broadcast
and we'll stay in the studio